let's go instead to our caller from the
972 area code who's calling from 972 I
gave it as Daniel from Texas oh yeah I
know what's going on I have a question
for you so I'm a big advocate as a
metaphor for all like many of your
listeners and yourself one of the
questions that come up from my friends
and family is should it be included in a
medicare-for-all option or whatever plan
that we come up with that we are
including all of the insurance employees
as part of retraining or even bringing
them on to a government Rand system or
should it be included in the budgeting
for that or how would you make sure that
a the Democratic Party since they'll be
the ones that end up pushing it through
how do you plan that they will do it
versus how do you think it should be
done to incorporate all those people who
lose their jobs well here's the thing a
lot of the people that work in the
health insurance industry don't really
need to be retrained in this they are
gonna need to find new jobs for sure but
it's not really the training piece that
they need help with what I mean by that
is so everyone who's a service provider
would just contain if your doctor you
stay a doctor if your nurse you stay a
nurse okay executive level people Human
Resources people you know all of these
people that work at health insurance
companies they're their skills would
still be in demand as is at other
companies we would just need to find
other companies for them so certainly
that would be a piece of it there's
really only a slice of health care
company employees that would really need
retraining I mean okay maybe you don't
need nearly as many medical billing
people and that's a really specific
narrow job that would be less relevant
you'll still need some of them because
remember single-payer still involves
billing it's just that there's one payer
so I actually don't know that retraining
is really the thing I think it's going
to be more a jobs program to figure out
where are they going to go do they get
involved in government infrastructure
programs do we transition them over to
green energy stuff like that is a
question I don't know that retraining is
really the issue I agree and I agree
with
just kind of wanted to set the stage
there for your thoughts on it and do you
think do you think that the numbers
should be included in any budgets only
have debates or discussions about that
regarding the the cost of that or do you
see it already shown in those numbers I
don't know the answer it's already in
the numbers I simply don't know yeah my
belief because I want to be transparent
is yeah if we think about what it's
going to cost to do Medicare for all I
want to include in that whatever costs
we are including to transition a lot of
the people that will lose their jobs
over to Nuge I would include that now
Republicans in bad faith would simply
say oh so it costs even more than you
said right I mean like so but so so for
political reasons maybe it's best not to
include it but if I really want to
holistically think about what's the
total cost here I would include the
transition costs for how the government
will support healthcare company
employees moving elsewhere great thank
you have a good one all right appreciate
the call thank you so much okay I don't
have time to take more calls today but I
will take calls again and I really
appreciate everybody who called in hope
to hear from you very very soon